joining us now are two men who have been
unfairly targeted by investigators
tangled up in that mess
informal presidential adviser Roger
stone author of the new book stones
rules how to win at politics business
and style and filmmaker Dinesh D'Souza
whose new movie death of a nation can we
save America a second time comes out
August 3rd looking forward to that both
of you it's great to have you both on
tonight so Dinesh let's start with you
whether it's the New York State Attorney
General's Office going after the Trump
foundation that gave away 19 million
dollars with no overhead no
administrative costs which a lot of
wealthy people do they set up their own
private foundations and then donate the
money from there whether that or the
what we find out about the bias of Peter
struck and the merry band of prosecutors
at the IG s from the IG s report what's
your take away tonight what should the
American people be thinking I think the
American people like me are arriving at
the dismaying realization that in
America today there are quite a few
criminals with badges now growing up as
I did in India we had a lot of
corruption and we knew that there were
criminals on the street and there were
criminals with badges but and the
criminals with badges are more dangerous
because they don't just violate the law
they corrupt the law they they exploit
the neutrality that you expect of them
they pervert the democratic process as
Peter struck tried to do by essentially
rigging I mean think about this this is
unprecedented the FBI attempting to in a
sense shape the outcome of a democratic
election so these are terrible things
happening now in America and I think the
American people are realized that
something needs to be done about them
and it's not enough to know about them
I'm action needs to be taken but it's
like you're operating in an alternative
universe if you watch any of the other
networks tonight it's no big deal let's
move on to stormy Daniels Roger I have
to read part of this report a lot of
stuff not being covered at all again by
other media outlets this is a quote from
the report November 9th 2016 a text
message
an FBI unidentified employee this is day
after the election all the people who
were initially voting for her mrs.
Clinton would not and were not swayed by
the decision the FBI put out in other
words I think the late the late Weiner
emails Trump supporters were all poor to
middle-class uneducated lazy POS that
think he will magically grant them jobs
for doing nothing they probably didn't
watch the debates aren't fully educated
on his policies and are stupidly wrapped
up in his unmerited enthusiasm has
anything ever encapsulated Roger the
elites disdain for the American people
no and I think when we get to the bottom
of it we're going to find out that that
at the end of the day the Obama Justice
Department the Obama FBI used the
authority and the capability of the
state and a bogus dossier to conduct
surveillance on the Republican candidate
for president and to infiltrate his
campaign with spies so FBI director
array today says well we respect the
congressional oversight at the same time
refusing to hand over any information
regarding that very FBI infiltration of
the Trump campaign Dinesh magically Jim
called me already has written an op-ed
for the New York Times okay it comes out
it's already written it's published
today I'm just gonna share a small part
of it he said this independent
assessment will be useful to thoughtful
people in an important contribution of
the historical record it's detailed
report should serve to both protect and
build the reservoir of trust and
credibility necessary for the DOJ and
the FBI to remain strong and independent
wild the man has learned Zippo Dinesh
well you also see the collusion between
the deep state operating behind closed
doors and the organs like the New York
Times which time these kinds of
counterpoints to immediately try to
defuse the impact of the IG report what
I want to know here Roger mentioned this
notion of getting to the bottom of it
the the tremendous kind of glee and
sense of immunity with which these
agents
the high level of operating suggests to
me that they would not do it without
someone giving the order I mean there's
that question from the Godfather who
gave the order and you know you know
Lord the old phrase qui Bona who
benefits is a good way to try to guess
who gave the order now Hillary benefits
but Hillary clearly couldn't have given
the order she was Secretary of State and
then she was out of the government Obama
on the other hand well very much did not
want Trump to win
he knew the Trump would try to erase his
legacy it'd be very embarrassing for him
to be succeeded by Trump I wonder if
Obama is the one who gave the order well
Roger we have some emails to that effect
final thoughts we already found out that
the president lied when he said he found
out about Hillary's you know private
email server when everybody else did now
we find out he's one of the 13 people
she communicated with on the private
server with using that private email
account so he lied about that when you
add to the fact that Peter struck says
in one of his text messages the
president wants to know everything the
question is very clear what did the
president know and when did he know it
he needs to answer that question I think
he needs to answer it under oath to the
Congress well he's gonna be going out on
the campaign trails apparently he's the
only person who can win elections for
the Democrats so he's he's going to be
fanning out this election season thank
you both phenomenal analysis as always
from both of you